Hello, hello!
Why is the pirate sad?
Why is he sad?
He looks... he looks...
frightening, actually.
Why is he sad?
Hello, everybody.
Gotta watch to find out.
Sorry, I'm eating a cough drop.
It has no pupils, and neither does his bird.
Maybe that's why he said.
He says, arg, I'm so sad.
I've got no arms, and we got no legs.
We got no pupils, and we got no bitches.
That's what he says.
Are you still sick, Vinto?
I am.
I'm still sick.
I went to the booth spittle today.
And I got prescribed antibiotics and steroids and an inhaler
and a chest x-ray.
The doctor said, you need help, little ID.
So...
She's getting jacks.
Yeah.
Yeah, they gave me the works.
The full course.
You're gonna be insanely healthy in like two weeks.
I hope so.
It sounds like they're worried if you're doing a chest
x-ray.
I think it's because I've had my cough for about a month.
now and i get i get weezy and uh i if i do any strenuous
stuff like if i move around a lot aka i dance practice i was
like on the ground like thinking of picking up retro rewind
and seeing minto playing today might push me to get it again
let's go
So, possible asthma.
I'm wondering that.
I'm not going to lie.
So everybody, stay healthy.
Even though I'm already dead.
I have to stay healthy.
Showed up at the hospital, ma'am.
I think you might be dead.
I'm sorry.
What do you mean you can't believe?
Wicker.
That's me.
but I'm not gonna let a little sickness get me down I'm
gonna let's let's go let's let's be kind and rewind to our
video store oh I wonder when this is supposed to take place
maybe like the 90s when did like the blockbusters and all of
those go away in the video rental stores.
2026.
Mid 2000s.
Here's some money for the cure mint sickness fund.
No!
Like a decade ago.
A decade ago would be 2016, by the way.
Streaming killed the video rental stores.
Not say those words.
I'm being...
Honest?
But it's fine!
It's 1999, baby!
The only thing I'm worried about right now computers gonna
crash because it doesn't know how to switch to zeros baby
actually I think people were very scared about that weren't
they weren't people like so scared of Y2K they were like the
entire the entire world is going to collapse it was a
serious issue here I am being like We don't know if we're
gonna be alive tomorrow.
I'm definitely not.
But we can still rent our favorite movie, The Sad Pirate.
And here's his iconic line.
Arr.
How will I...
How will I water me plant with no arms and no legs and no
pupils and no bitches?
But we're...
He'll be alright, girl.
Oh no, I'm already dead.
I'm a ghost, actually.
2016 was a decade ago when Mint Phantom attacking my life
points directly.
Don't think about it.
It's 1999.
My birthday was at the start of the month.
Can I get a late happy birthday?
Agent Heroic, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Sorry, I'm late!
I'm sorry, I sound congested.
Let's play the game.
Empty save slot.
Oh, wow!
Our little area!
We're right next to Magic Scoop!
Oh, it's not even 1999.
We have nine more years to worry about.
Weather up.
Easy.
it.
My first PC was Y2K proof.
Sadly, it wasn't Windows ME proof when I installed it over
Windows 98.
Ah.
ME time is so cute though.
Was there a 98 time?
Windows 98 time?
I only remember ME and I remember 7.
Anyone want to hang out?
I just rented the Goonies and Diddy Kong Racing and my mom
just ordered Pete so Amito is my birthday.
Just were we happy birthday?
10 and 11 had tons.
XP.
Hold on.
I'm going to look it up.
What XP ton was.
I can't remember her at all.
Okay, hold on.
XP ton.
No, not XP.
98 ton.
Wait, who am I thinking of?
Look at that.
Thank you!
Wait.
Oh, I don't recognize her at all.
Windows 98, Tan.
Okay, wait, what about XP Tan?
Wait, XP Tan.
Oh, I remember her!
Oh, I remember XP Tan!
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She was so pretty.
She's like real Bishojo.
Ah!
Today is my birthday!
Dad, happy birthday!
It's okay, Thomas, the goat, glasses, blue hair, made
swimsuit.
I know.
I wish I, I mean, I don't want to know what Windows 11 time
would be though.
Isn't there a Linux mint?
Can I be the mascot?
Can I be mint time?
I'll be mint time.
I heard it's like the easiest Linux to get into too.
That it's like very, very friendly.
Oh, finally!
Oh my gosh.
My prescriptions are finally ready.
Sorry.
They were supposed to be ready hours ago.
Yippee!
Why are they ready now?
I can't go pick it up.
I'm streaming.
I'll get it tomorrow.
Yippee!
It's 1990, yo.
The golden age of movie rentals and your dream is about to
become reality.
You are now the proud owner of a video store.
Your first day is about to begin, but the shop needs a
little love.
Time to set up a few shelves, buy some movies, and decorate
your store before your first customer walks through the
door.
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Let me take a sippy.
yeah let's block some busters baby oh oh whoa my goodness
sensitivity hold on holy what other currencies can we do we
could do oh my gosh wait it's blocked by the chat we could
be ultimate weaves and have our currency in yen
okay that's so much better to learn the controls check The
contextual menu.
Why do I need to crouch?
Ah!
I'm not a freak.
I didn't mean to look at her like that.
Rocket bar.
Let's see.
Let's check out the neighborhood.
Neon lanes.
Oh.
store unattended.
What is this?
Oh, it's inside.
You're ready to... Good golly, ma'am.
I guess the 90s, they don't wear bras, huh?
Oh, I think she heard that.
Sorry.
Sorry, Steve from Blue's Clues.
Need help?
We know our movies.
Oh, access the catalog.
okay whoa oh we got a fish and everything I know the
characters in this the models are kind of fun you know wait
let's check out a little bit hello mr.
he looked out on me hello ma'am hello yes yes would you like
to come into retro why is it called retro rewind if it's the
90s you can rename your store by clicking on the logo.
Um, maybe not yet.
Oh look, we've got Batman, Legally Distinct.
What's this one supposed to be?
We have Jason, we got Jaws.
Oh!
Slotbuster.
What the heck is that?
Buster.
Power Patrol.
Oh my gosh, Sheriff Andy.
I feel like we should call it like Ghost Buster instead of
Block Buster or Retro Buster.
Wait, what is it?
What's this name?
Please call it Retro Busting?
I don't know, actually.
Wait, Retro...
What is the name of this game?
Wait.
Retro Buster.
rewind all right catalog show us which we got order three
shelves okay how much money I got 550 bucks and a dream one
two three and I got a Tamagotchi here which I don't think
I'll ever feed oh no no I want to feed this guy store level
unlocks.
First we get shelves, then we get slushies.
New movie genre.
Who the hell is this?
Ibu Pilgrimage to the last blockbuster in Oregon.
Wait, I thought it was in Alaska.
Oh, oh, our first...
We haven't made a dollar yet, so...
Oh, store expansion!
I can take over this whole place.
Okay, interesting.
Alright, our shelves.
Oh, why is it grainy?
Wow, okay.
Oh, okay, here we go.
One.
Three to pick up and move objects you have placed.
Pick up.
Those are mixed movies.
And these are...
More mixed movies.
What's over here?
Oh, the toilet.
Oh.
Wait, what is this?
Can my Oshie be dead, mate?
Yes?
To whom it may concern, please be respectful of others and
try to keep this bathroom clean.
The last time I attempted to use the toilet, I simply
couldn't.
pee on the floor than in the bowl if you miss you clean
that's the rule oh my god that happened to me I went to a
maid cafe I was gonna say the other day it really was the
other day I went to a maid cafe and I went to the bathroom
and first of all there was a sign that said both boys and
girls use this bathroom so don't lift up the seat and what
do you know the seat was lifted up of course it was but then
there was just pee all over the floor and I was like
straddling it trying to avoid the pee so first of all you
will you lifted and then you missed how is that possible all
I'm thinking at that moment is physical media is forever by
laser disc it's
very easy to miss then why don't you sit down.
She got no aim.
It was like so much pee.
I was like, what the hell happened here?
But I really needed a pee too.
Literal skill issue.
First time I found out that anime was a thing was in
blockbuster in the late 90s.
It had its own shelf different from other cartoons.
See if you miss you clean.
That's the rule that guy did not listen actually this is
very clean But I who is this my mom?
We got a toaster back here we have What was that?
Wait, oh, I was gonna say there was definitely something
We're playing thrillers or something.
What is this oh Oh
I'll be sure not to rewind the movies and not to put them in
their proper cases.
How dare you!
They came from Space Chapter Beamed!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
Run or something?
I don't know.
The thing you could have prevented happened!
That's it.
That's the movie.
Okay.
Anyway, we got...
Oh.
We've got lots of apples.
Wanted by the police?
Be kind, rewind.
Always be nice to customers.
Wanted by police.
Have you seen this, man?
Alright, we're setting up recovered tapes not displayed on
shelves.
Okay.
Oh, save.
Save my progression.
Alright, my game has been saved.
It's 8 a.m.
and I'm...
Oh, use the design tool, Lee, to change the look of the
walls, the floors, the ceiling!
Oh, is this going to cost me money?
What if I... What's a...
Whoa.
Whoa!
Oh, I don't think it does.
Oh, this is obnoxious.
Oh, this is terrible.
Wait, this is like...
This is like the arcade flooring.
such cutting commentary is your store named mint cinema it
could be whoa whoa whoa there's so much customization oh
what if I made like the ugliest store would people come in
and made their eyes burn wait yes wait though this is the
arcade rug oh my gosh but we're not in arcade but i don't
care oh wow wait i didn't notice did it cost us money or not
oh it didn't
an accent wall it's very important wait how do i oh i can
even do these okay well actually these are the accent poles.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, nice.
Wait, was there another pole?
Oh, yeah, yeah, here we go.
Accent pole.
Oh, my God.
That's actually not so bad.
Why is it so grainy?
YouTube's not gonna like that.
Little grain.
Oh, this could be so much worse.
Oh, it's like a filter because oh, okay.
Oh, oh, here we go.
Mixed.
Wait, how do I not make it mixed?
Poiple.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, how do I make it?
How do I make it not mix take
me back oh when i put a movie on it okay okay all right
access your computer oh there we go locate okay here we go
from your computer order movies in the market oh it's free
it's free it's free it's all free okay what do we got here
baby the the beast freak show oh my god and it's rainbow we
got the beast freak this is the perfect this is this is
gonna fly off the shelves i know it it's like my first job
at blockbuster dial mint autobiography what else we got oh
wait why are they shaking it's wrong are they oh
everything's fine wait i The dessert's wrong number.
It's a drama.
Okay, oh, so this is now horror.
And that's now drama.
The dessert's wrong.
That sounds dramatic.
What do we got here?
The lonely inmate.
Aww.
Can I pick up more than one at a time?
Oh, okay, thank goodness.
oh my hands are full okay we got a scary sailor in the tent
that one's horror right
a scary sailor the bodybuilders last melody that sounds the
invasive bowl the undead barrel the light keeper's uncle
what are these titles the offering of bathtub the kid
everything is like starts with the the blank blank blank
blank skull brain implants okay finally the last princess in
Blackwood Manor grandma's paladin pot why is this a drama
okay what else we got oh oops oh i'll come the dessert freak
show we keep getting wait is this a sequel
inheriting the lady my toaster never caught the monstrous
shipmate it's a spin-off we'll put them next to each other
oh oh uh Oh, look, we have a couple that look similar,
right?
Wait, where'd it go?
I just had it.
Oh, the dessert freak show.
The beast freak show and the dessert freak show.
And then we had ones with bowls.
Here we go.
Wait.
The buffalo.
Oh, this is a buffalo.
The buffalo that followed you home.
The angry buffalo.
The werewolf, our last guest.
I'd rather not thank you so much for the time, Gator.
Knockout Gator.
Gangsta.
The heirloom love affair.
Skeleton failed studies.
Why is that?
We have a double?
Uh-oh, we got a dupe, you guys.
Oh, wait.
Just kidding.
That was me.
I picked it up.
Oh, I ran out of space, though.
These are going to have to be mixed, I guess.
The hot...
Wait.
Oh, this is drama, my bud.
Oh, it changed to mixed.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Horror.
The heart haunting the mansion.
Was there one still on the floor?
Yes.
The scary...
The scary marine.
In the cornfield.
As opposed to a normal marine.
He's the scary marine.
Cupcake brain implants.
What are with the implants?
We had this one too.
Oh, nope, that's the monstrous shipmate.
Just kidding.
Wait, we have skull brain implants.
The offering of the tentacle.
They will come for the heirloom.
Oh my goodness.
The rocket man that followed you home.
The troll... Wait, oh no, we're out of space.
Okay, it's gonna have to be mixed.
Save your progress.
Alright.
you can use the employee time clock to manually save there's
also auto save feature at the beginning of each new day okay
nobody in here all right is this a horror game absolutely
adore this game it's so chill and stress-free here's some
skews you can search on the black market on your pc wait
what you're giving me skews wait how do i look.
Wait, black market!
Oh my god!
Five, five, five, four, nine, one.
Say it!
It's a hot dog!
I'll buy it.
Wait, it's the black market.
Is that okay?
Whatever.
Um.
One, two, three, eight, eight, two.
The vengeful ghost!
Dang, this one's expensive.
Thank you.
page for the super chat and for the codes we're on the black
market baby who ordered the hot t-rex
it's expensive i think it's gonna sell like hotcakes though
i think i need another shelf
is the sensitivity okay for you guys i could change it if
not
Something feels a little off about it to me.
Satan and his hot dog on the top of the shelf.
Wait, what is this one?
A whore.
Yeah.
Actually, top of the shelf.
Top of the shelf.
Oh my god!
I don't like a copy of The Vengeful Ghost, please.
Not for sale.
what was it?
Uh, please.
What kind of shelves did I do before?
I think purple, right?
Poiple.
Oh, this one I didn't do.
Actually, both of these I didn't do.
Well, okay, oh, sorry.
What if, though, we changed them?
Like, you know, horror can be one color and drama can be one
color.
We can make them, we can make them match, you know?
Adult should be, yeah, maybe adult should be like...
You have to really come into this door.
You have to really search.
What is it?
Oh, from the outside look up at the front signage and...
Oh!
The name!
Now we can get the name!
Oh.
There we go.
Wow!
Whoa!
We can... Whoa!
Roboto.
Minto Buster
Ghost Buster
Zuck Light color There's so much customization in this game
Oh, we gotta make it more green Oh, that's perfect, that's
perfect, that's perfect
oh my god they are gonna sue no they're not they don't care
they don't care about me in 2001 i broke the family tv
because my parents refused to take me to blockbuster to
print my pokemon go photos
pokemon go like the app that came out in like 2019 or not
2019 when was it 2016 Snap?
Meow Minto!
I can't stay on my side because I'm at work.
Have a good day of work!
Snap.
I didn't have Pokemon Snap.
I named mine Tapehole.
That's strange.
We'll do Ghostbusters.
What are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
Helping pay the legal fees.
No, it doesn't exist yet.
It doesn't exist yet.
When did Ghostbusters come out?
1999.
I don't know.
I don't know when it came out.
The on sign!
We are open!
Oh my gosh.
Serve three customers.
Wait, can I pass out some?
Oh.
You can carry up the five flyers.
Hello.
Oh.
Excuse me.
You.
Oh.
The customers are lining up.
Shut up.
Uh.
Uh, hello.
Uh, where wolf?
Our last guest.
classic.
The Beast Freak Show!
Let's go?
Thank you.
When the balance is settled, hit the space bar to close the
cash register.
Oh, wait.
I have to give her $11 back?
Wait.
Received?
Yeah, $11.50?
Oh, okay, okay.
Thank you!
Math.
Oh, the Dessert freak show.
I love it.
Amount due.
A single dollar.
There you are, sir.
Okay, this is easy math.
This is easy math.
Holy!
The troll strategy.
The dessert's wrong number.
Nice.
You are free to go.
Inheriting the lighting.
Yeah, it's a busy night.
Holy cow!
We're making bank!
A mount due, a dollar.
You're free to go.
Did you get the- You are a freaky lady.
You're a freaky lady.
You know that?
I know what you're into.
Oh my god!
And she got the vengeful ghost!
She got the vengeful ghost!
And who ordered the hot T-Rex?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
You're free to go.
And with white hair?
Wait a second!
Wait a second.
I think she...
Wait, she had white hair and she was wearing green.
She had a freaky...
She was like, I'm smiling.
Wait a second.
You're free to go.
I'm in the game.
Just one?
Really?
We have such an amazing selection.
I mean, we're going to have just one movie?
Why is it so expansive?
Oh, just kidding.
You get 16 back.
Sorry, I misunderstood.
I like the way they, like, just kind of drop it on the
shelf, you know?
Two dollars back.
Yeah.
There you go.
Hello.
Oh.
heart hunting the mansion oh thank you yeah sixteen dollars
ten five one there you go oh i can't even take a potty break
this is crazy the one lady who rented 90s ibuz bilay i like
to imagine you having that exact reaction behind the counter
and embarrassing the poor freaky lady What do you mean?
There you go.
Thank you.
Oh.
You talking to me?
I'm looking for a horror movie that will make me pee my
pants!
I think everybody's a freak here.
Sure.
Let me get you a scary sailor in the tent.
Yeah, you have to pay for that though.
Okay, good.
She wants to pee her pants.
Hello.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, she's getting those series.
Oh, thank you.
You'll get $3.50 back.
Hello, sir.
$2.
Yep.
Thank you.
Have a nice day.
nice day hello you want to pee your pants tonight you better
buy it you know we sell shorts too not yet we will if
there's a demand six seven eight have a good day why is
steve looking at me like that oh wow oh it's 6 30 what time
do i close I gotta get more customers, and before we close,
I don't know what time we close.
You?
Hello, I just opened today.
It's a grand opening.
Oh, my bad.
I'm littering, but I don't, I'm not a criminal to the...
Oh, I don't have any more.
I'm not a criminal to this, to everybody, you know?
Oh, they picked that bird on purpose, because that's like
the childhood bird.
That sound, you know, that bird.
What is that?
A pigeon?
What did you get?
The monstrous shipmate, huh?
All right.
Wait, why do I know her name?
How do you have a membership?
What the hell?
Morning dove.
Satan in his heart, dog.
You got it.
Uh, six.
Why is it only 350?
Oh, because it's an old movie.
Paige, you're sabotaging my business!
Close the door to finish the day.
Oh, you're my last customer.
Thank you.
250.
Ah!
Wow.
What a day.
How much money did we make?
Also, we're gonna have cotton candy and popcorn and...
This is the slushies.
Reserved.
Return desk.
Ooh, these streets are smoking.
Alright, wait.
Accidentally, can I put it back?
Store flyer, okay.
No one else is showing up.
8 p.m.
everybody goes home because that's when the scariness
happens.
Oh, yeah baby!
General shells!
New shells are available!
Let's go!
Oh, it's raining.
Take a look at the calendar.
Okay.
The calendar is updated every morning and affects gameplay
in exciting ways with new releases, special events and
weather forecast updates.
A task list with various objectives is also available to
gain extra rewards.
Tomorrow a newly released movie will be available for
purchase on the new tab!
Oh, wait, what's today?
Monday the 2nd?
Tomorrow is a new movie release?
Wait, what is the Remembrance Day?
A day where many watching movie films that honor the past.
If you want a video that's sure to make money...
Oh, thanks!
Wait, I'm gonna get it.
6-9-2-2-3-411.
The ghost of my fantasy!
Wait, it's another...
It's another adult.
Why is it bad?
It has one star.
Rotten tomatoes is eating it up.
I mean, they're tearing it apart.
The ghost of my fantasy.
It's $71.
You think anyone will buy it or rent it?
endless trash they don't know what's good maybe it is good
okay we'll take a risk
we need more adult films oh yes the adult films are coming
oh is this many clients will bring back oh the return okay
process return movies at the return station so they can be
rented out again select the movies on the rack to your right
them in the system you can return you can return and hold up
to 10 movies oh oh wait what is this and then i like hold it
oh some movies need to be who rented wait what was this oh
oh oh there we go oh oh i have to okay who rented They will
come for the heirloom!
I have you on file, your membership.
My friend would like to borrow that movie.
Yeah?
Critics don't understand the art of adult films.
So true.
Some movies are reserved by customers.
Place the movie in the reserve shelves to the left.
Oh, someone reserved this one.
Okay.
Very cool.
So I'm just checking them.
I mean we we did like rent a bajillion movies yesterday so
okay now we go put in the oh look our shelves are basically
empty that's insane holy cow like we we did good
preemptively paying for late fees boss don't don't be late
sorry my brother jammed cookies in the VCR before I could
I'm trying to...
Typical little bro stuff.
I get it.
Reserved.
Someone reserved the king's famous pie.
I've heard that one is really good.
I wonder if she liked it.
This one's crazy.
It's shiny, so it goes up top.
All right.
Nice.
Our shop is popping off, baby.
Turn the onside.
Okay, let's go.
Come in.
Come on.
You.
You, you.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, oh.
You.
Oh, no.
Oh, people are coming inside.
No.
What are you?
You?
Hello.
Oh, timing.
I was already coming.
Okay, nice.
Come here, come here.
Come to my store.
We're losing money.
I bought a really expensive movie today and it needs to go.
It needs to go.
Oh, you're free to go.
Oh, just kidding.
Sorry.
Oh.
Wait.
I messed up.
I-I-O-U-16.
Just kidding.
There you go.
You're free- Errm.
Errm.
Knockout gangster and inheriting the lady, huh?
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
You're free to go.
Having a job seems stressful.
Yeah, I'm stressing.
The troll strategy, man.
You're free to go.
Brittany.
Oh!
ghost oh my god anna you're gonna love this one i bought it
specifically for this shop it's exclusive no one else has it
you have to only
david david knows what he wants uh-oh the other movie hasn't
oh the time is still oh my gosh i just realized i gotta like
hurry the clock is still ticking.
David knows ball.
Have a good day.
What do you want?
You have a good... I rented a movie last week and it was
brutally bad.
Sure, a good movie.
Wait, someone's calling me?
Hello?
Grandma's Paladin Pie?
Do I have that?
Last copy, baby.
Alright, um, a good movie.
The, the beast, wait, it's you again.
What are you grabbing?
No, no, this isn't what, this is for him.
A good, no, critic movie, okay.
Oh, it's bad critic.
Here we go, here we go.
Oh, she's back.
Today is normal.
Come on.
Oh, I saw it!
I saw it happen!
You never suspect the ladies in the chinchilla sweaters.
I swear.
Oh my god, it happened before my very eyes!
It
happened before my very eyes!
And it's a grandma!
150.
You're free to go.
Oh, that's a cat, not a chinchilla.
Oh yeah, my store is empty now.
You're right.
I need to give you five dollars and I need to get more
stuff.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, this is so stressful.
We have movies.
Don't leave.
I promise.
I swear.
Oops.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
These suckers.
We have movies.
Don't leave.
I've got half a movie.
It's in my hands.
Oops.
Oh.
Hello.
Oh, one second.
He won't get mad that I went to pass out flyers, really.
Oh, no.
You're returning.
I'm sorry.
Oh, God.
I can't.
I'm too busy.
What do you want?
Grandma's Paladin Pie.
Here you are, sir.
One second.
Everybody who returned these, oh, sir.
They all rewound them, right?
Oh, nice.
Horror?
Drama?
Okay, nice.
Hello, hello.
Thanks, Kaido.
I sneezed.
Why did she say hey?
Why'd she say hey like that?
Goodbye, Jacob.
What if I addressed everybody by their names, you know?
What was that one called?
Lonely inmate.
So sad.
Oh, I forgot to say her name.
Clara, the offering of the bathtub, huh?
Yeah.
I've seen that one like five times.
You're good to go.
Whoa!
Buying out our store.
Are you?
Jackson!
Oh, okay.
One second.
350 is your change.
Thank you for your service.
Hello.
Buffalo that followed.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
Wow.
I'm glad you guys enjoyed the sneeze.
You guys say it's a good sneeze?
That's my normal sneeze.
That's just my regular old sneeze.
Nothing special about it.
Three!
Oh, the shells are empty!
Yeah, because we're awesome.
We're so good at this.
All of our movies are awesome.
What did you want?
Last princess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here you go.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh...
Because, like, we're the best movie store in town, baby.
I made all these movies myself.
Good,
we're good.
What do you want?
Yeah.
The buffalo that followed you home?
Yeah, okay.
There you go.
You're a natural.
Sneezer and sailor.
Oh, oh, hello.
I'm stuck babysitting tonight.
Do you have an old movie?
That's a drama.
Yes?
Is this old?
It's a...
drama old movie then no i cannot help you sir whatever what
a loser you're gonna rent it anyway oh my god this guy sucks
eight dog you're free to go what if i gave somebody all back
in pennies why are you so angry Don't look at me like that!
I should have...
Enjoy your movie, Jack!
Nobody's returned anything either.
Wait, I have no movies.
Maybe I need to buy more movies.
The mixed movie bundle.
I just rented the movie, The Light Keeper's Uncle, and
there's a piece of gum stuck on the tape.
That's honestly pretty nasty.
I'm sorry.
Oh, wait until the new movie tomorrow.
You're so right, you're so right, you guys are so right.
Our store could use some decorations.
Can we buy any decorations?
Oh, decorations!
Oh, we can get a frame.
We can get a doormat!
That's kind of cute.
We'll buy that.
We'll buy the frame stand.
We'll get a frame.
Equipment.
Okay, we can't buy any of that.
Stations?
Okay, none of that either.
That was mine.
Your gum or your...
I would go to the plaza and order Chinese food, walk next
door and rent a horror movie.
and by the time I got it the food was ready every weekend
life was simple but it was good that sounds so good I would
go and my blockbuster had like the video game set up so I
would play the games that I didn't have or like you know the
consoles and stuff this is our mat
Oh, it's so cute.
And this is our frame.
Oh, there's a big boy.
The enchanter is here.
I don't have that movie.
All right, good job, team.
We earned $134.
printed 33 movies but had 32 returned one of my brothers and
I oh one of my brothers and I would go to blockbuster and
then not find anything we wanted to wander aimlessly until
we picked out something random and terrible that was like
the joy of of just going and seeing all the different the
different covers and being like I don't know if this is good
I can't hover over it and see a you, I just have to trust.
movie, no release movie available.
The movie will be considered new for seven days.
Okay.
What is this?
13 bodies out on VHS today.
Oh.
13 bodies.
Oh, Stan V bundle promotion.
Oh, water or five copies or more, I get a freestand E.
How many should I get?
Like, how many people?
Eight?
Eight sounds good, maybe.
That's a lot of bodies.
Get 13.
Can I afford 13?
Just barely.
Oh, the price goes down.
It's kind of nice.
I remember finding the random new anime rental at the
blockbuster.
It was like finding gold.
Yeah, yeah.
Better get 13.
13 bodies.
I have $7 left in my name.
I've invested everything into this store.
Where's my standy?
This is like me buying Metal Gear merch.
Oh, I have to purchase so many so that I can get the special
thing.
Okay.
He will hunt you, he will find you, he will kill you.
Movie gallery turned me into a weed because my mom thought
Princess Mononoke was a Pokemon thing.
My dad stopped her from turning it off halfway.
Thank you for this live movie gallery.
I watched Princess Mononoke!
I watched the dub and my mom got really mad.
She was like, I thought this was a movie for kids.
And it's all because of one line.
drinks like some sort of soup or something and he goes mmm
tastes like super donkey piss my mom was like this is not
appropriate for the children she
was like yeah what how could they say piss in my but I was
allowed to watch Shrek I don't understand.
I once rented Amadeus because the cover art made me think it
was an anime about an evil wizard.
Mozart's cool too, I guess.
I don't think I've ever seen that one.
Amadeus.
Hope you're feeling better.
Thanks, Brendan.
You too!
I'm just throwing... Oh, my hands are full.
I threw two copies.
Alright, let's see.
What if we put it, like, here?
No, no, no!
Oh.
I can fit it on the whole thing.
Nice.
What is this?
Meet me out back at 9 p.m.
every Tuesday and Thursday.
If you're after exclusive movies and deals, I'll crack the
door open to let you know I'm here.
I'll be waiting.
The tape dealer.
What's today?
Oh!
It's a Tuesday.
I'm gonna meet the... Oh no!
I have one extra!
Did you guys convince me to get 13?
These shelves can only hold 12!
Gosh, dang it.
One copy for me?
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe we move this like next to it, right?
And then we move yeah, this like over here.
Yeah.
Yeah, that works.
That works.
13 bodies.
Here, here, here.
Oh, oh.
Sorry, I'm trying to get out of that.
All right.
Um, our returns?
You're us.
Thank you, Colmo.
Your mom drew the line at donkey piss and not when the guy
gets his head shot off by a bow and arrow.
I guess not.
Oh, I didn't check the new shelves.
Wait, the king's famous pie.
They never came and got it.
Vengeful Ghost is back, baby.
Come
on.
The dessert freak show.
Some customers return their rentals late.
The system automatically adds a late fee to their membership
ID.
During their next purchase, the checkout computer will flag
the outstanding fee.
Oh, uh-oh.
Yeah, we have nothing in my store.
Actually, though, I can't buy any more shelves because I'm
broke when buying all these dang movies.
Late.
Reserve.
Oh, who ordered the hot T-Rexes?
Preserve.
This one is like going crazy though.
late why are we having so many late movies now huh this is
crazy oh look at this though everything is full or not full
but you know what i mean that would be me who reserved this
movie this clearly i mean it has good critics so clearly the
people know what they like i'm i'm all for it I'm all for
the people flying their freak flag.
Let's go.
All right.
Let's grab these.
On.
Hey, hey, hey.
Don't walk past.
Oh, I have.
Oh, you said.
Oh.
Hey, what's wrong?
Hmm.
Oh, you're already planning.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Err.
One second.
Hello.
The dessert freak show.
I have it right here for you, sir.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hello.
What do we have here?
Are people getting a new movie?
Gonna be flying off the shelves?
Miss your boss T-Rex is bringing sexy back.
Meow.
What was your most visited rental place?
Hollywood videos a lot.
I think probably...
I don't know.
I can't remember.
I think a blockbuster probably.
One second.
Knockout gangster.
I...
There's a lot going on, huh?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
I thought the new movie would be like more popular than it
for $50
okay geez always I think blockbuster yeah was my place of
choice not that I had a choice probably
everybody I like that we just have spooky movies everyone's
in the mood for a good horror Yeah.
Hollywood video is cool.
Thank you, sir.
Um, I know I returned my last rental late, but the movie was
so good I just couldn't stop watching it.
You understand, right?
Lady, I have $60 to my name.
Charge the fee.
Well, it is what it is.
She handled it so well.
Thank you.
Joshua, the ghost of my fantasy.
Splendid choice, sir.
And the dessert freak show?
I think you might be an Ibu.
I think you might be a Ibu!
Vengeable Ghost.
Nice, nice.
A classic.
Joshua is most wise.
Wait, why isn't the new movie flying off the shelves?
Oh, her eyes are like...
Oh, okay.
I thought they were going everywhere.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your business.
What does this mean?
Reserved.
Alright.
Oh.
Hi.
One moment.
One moment, please.
We need movies.
For the people.
Silly bee.
Minto movies can't fly?
No, no, I swear.
Okay, one second, one second.
I've really thought that there would be like, wait, how did
these...
Oh, I guess the others were rented, right?
Hold on, I'm adjusting my shelving.
Oops.
We're making it nice and neat and clean.
The offering of the bathtub.
Yes, I just actually put that out.
Thank you very much.
Hello, sir.
13 bodies, a brand new...
Steve.
Nice.
Give me the cash.
You're free to go.
Err.
We'll get this guy and then we'll help that guy.
I don't even have time to pass out flyers!
How will the people know that I'm here?
Is 13 bodies supposed to be like...
I think it's like, I think it's Jason though, no, look at
the mask.
Maybe Jason's just, oh, shoot, well, that's fine.
Jason's starting to do some math, you know?
Oh, Michael.
Michael, the king, the one who ordered, who ordered the hot
T-Rex.
It's you.
There you are.
I'll give this a shot.
What do you mean by that?
Michael?
I might have...
A fear...
A fear I might have...
gotten too many 13 bodies.
Hey.
Why are you saying that so sexy?
Wait, what do you mean I gave him a free movie?
What do you mean I give the movie for free?
Oh, wow.
Finally.
Oh my gosh.
It's been here forever.
You gave that lady a 750.
Didn't it say to give her a 750?
Wait, did I mess up?
Oh, the lady didn't need change.
Oh, no!
I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm
gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna...
My business!
We're gonna go under!
I saw 750!
Oh my god!
You?
The buffalo?
I just put that up.
Good thing I did.
Oh, amount due?
Zero.
You are free to go.
I won't give you change.
Oh, we still have customers?
Yes, yes.
So generous.
No!
Yeah, actually all the 13 bodies are gone.
Let's go.
There you go.
We just have that skelly right there.
He's our last movie.
What is this?
Skeleton failed study.
That sounds like a terrible movie, I'm not gonna lie.
Go see what's happening in the back alley.
Oh, so it's before you close, okay.
Is that the lady in our bath room?
Isn't that the lady in the toilet?
That's definitely her.
13 bodies.
Hmm.
You might want to invest.
Oh, you do have blinds.
What's in here?
It looks like a little boat.
Oh, curious.
The tape dealer!
I've got bootleg movies for half their market value.
Exclusive adult titles and the occasional holographic
rarity.
Only the good stuff.
I'm here every Tuesday and Thursday at 9 p.m.
Okay.
Here's the 750 million.
I could plus interest.
Andy, thank you.
Oh.
So I mean, your movie was late.
What's the interest for?
This is his home.
A shady dealer.
Wait, is this the guy that's wanted by the cops?
I think 100% is the guy wanted by the cops.
I think he has anything Japanese.
I know, Sumi Masai.
Then...
The swimmer in good hands...
He's an adult.
Two ladies for one dessert?
I've been searching for that one.
The dead farmer's rooster.
The bad boy with his treasure.
The cigarette.
My only friend.
It's an old movie.
That's good.
This one's just horror.
We don't need that one.
Thanks, mister.
Thank you.
Very good.
Get it?
It's cheap?
Oh, I guess we could go back and get it.
This is crazy.
Oh my god, all the freaks are going to be so excited to see
that we have new adult movies.
All right, I'll go get it.
Give me the rooster.
I guess we are out of stuff technically right now, so...
We'll get more things in the morning.
Maybe I buy some more shelves.
We do have a new...
Thin movie shelf.
Oh, we actually...
Wait, we have so many movies.
Wait, I mean, so many shelves.
Huh.
new releases movie show boy that's fun oh i can barely buy
it though okay hold on
let's do gotta make an adult section behind a curtain i
can't buy curtains did they even have curtains maybe behind
a cactus
i'm so asleep you guys snack shelf I'm hungry too I didn't
have dinner yet let's buy this
and we'll just stick it somewhere stick it right there stick
it to the man yeah and we can start putting some stuff on
there too very good this game is kind of addictive the
sloshies sir frozen drinks You've completed your first three
days as a proud video store owner.
I am proud.
Oh my gosh, Ghostbuster.
It's doing so well.
It's time to take your business to the next level.
Improve your shop with decorations, snack displays, arcade
machines, and other goodies to draw on more customers.
Keep an eye out for special events like the Fall Harvest
Festival happening this weekend.
Unlock new movie genres, hire staff, expand your store's
footprint and discover plenty more surprises.
Can you un- Magic scoop looks delicious.
Do you want to collab?
With my store?
Actual adult title I've seen, my ass is haunted.
My ass is haunted.
Thank you so much for the fact it's here!
What is that language?
Yeah, I have skeleton failed studies for you.
It's one of our few genres, uh, dramas left, I mean.
Wait, so...
See the catalog for repair info?
Equipment?
Sations?
Oh!
Repair it!
Oh, it was $50.
Okay.
Well, hopefully, um...
Ooh, I don't like the way that came out.
Nice.
Everybody watched it.
They all enjoyed.
It's all 13 bodies.
Oops, all bodies.
Oops.
Nice.
It really is just all 13 bodies.
All 13 of them.
I haven't had a slushie in forever.
You know what's really sad?
My existence, I can't have carbonation, right?
And a lot of slushies have carbonation for some reason.
I couldn't tell you why.
166 bodies.
I had an employee who tried to extort a $9 raise by
threatening to report me to the cops for selling bootleg
tapes.
Are you working my store or?
Regrettably, the bubbles can be really nice, but I can't
have it.
Oh.
Why are we not rewinding our movies?
For the undead barrel?
Late.
Okay, finally, good.
We're getting our dramas back.
Good, good, good, good.
Really doing...
through a rough time right now.
Oh, Captain, I'm sorry.
Oh, I hope you have a better day tomorrow.
Alright.
I keep wanting to say, it's put my ghost, my fantasy under
the horror.
But it's not.
It's sexy.
Look at this, the bad boy with this treasure.
The two ladies for one dessert is kind of insane.
I'm not gonna lie.
Like, I think we struck gold.
That one is going to be flying off the shelves.
Like, actually.
That one is going to be our most popular...
No.
Maybe not more popular than T-Rex.
Probably.
20 space champ VHS teams.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got you.
Wait, it says we can hire people, right?
Where?
What's our data?
Who ordered the hot T-Rex?
It's been printed three times.
Oh,
this is how you get the skill.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, look.
There's some...
Sexy explosive in the sauna?
Oh.
Oops.
Exploded in the song.
Funding the $9 raise.
Don't report a manky.
Let's see.
So today's Wednesday is cloudy.
Oh, look at this.
We can collect.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
I'm getting money.
Oh my gosh.
Let's not forget to get these then.
Oh, shoot.
Tape dealer.
New release set.
What is this?
Meteor shower?
Oh, sci-fi movies.
I don't even have those.
We're rich, baby.
Generate $10,000 in total revenue.
Revenue.
Hey, Saba-da!
I rented a few movies from you, and one of them feels
cheaper than the others.
The quality doesn't seem the same.
If it breaks, I won't...
I hope you won't charge me a fee since it already feels low
quality.
Okay, sorry.
What does that mean?
How is my movie?
What is this?
Oh, staff book.
Okay, applicants.
Oh, I can't get up.
Why would you tell me to hire somebody?
I can't.
I can't even hire anybody.
I'm still working this all myself.
All right.
Oh.
Wait, can I?
or allied I will take my flyer..
No, don't walk faster.
Don't walk away.
You know you want this.
I like slip it into their back pocket.
Yeah, you want that?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You, you, you, you.
And you.
I hate movies!
What the hell?
These people are returning their movies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You and you.
nice oh it can't be a two girls you know it can't be a
reference to that instead of watching the meteor shower
they're going to watch sci-fi movies it doesn't have to make
sense sophie my gal you have great taste have a great day
hello thank you slow poke scarlet over here all right come
on i'm running a business here i got it i got it yes hannah
this is all yours or it could be somebody else's I'm not
sure yeah it's not referencing anything thank you thank you
oh I told you two ladies for one dessert I'm telling you
make back thank you for the gifted I'm telling you it's
gonna be a hit
Thank you, Jackson.
I remember you.
Grace, the offering of the tentacle, really?
It's not in the adult section.
Hello?
What was that one?
Cigarette, my only friend?
Hey.
Hey, sexy lady.
Skelet- Yes, I have that one.
There you are.
Yes.
Yeah.
So far, I'm really enjoying this.
What's really nice about it more so is that the UI isn't
like really obnoxious, you know what I mean?
Oh, you would have cherry!
How do I do this?
Pick, pick, pick it, put it in, and cherry.
Oh, I hope that's good.
Hmm.
Uh-oh.
I'm not paying a stupid, dumb, useless, ridiculous,
pointless $2 late fee.
Charge the fee.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
The slushy!
She's going on my...
She's going on the... She's going on the naughty list.
Oh my god!
I have to clean that up there.
You don't want the air Loom Love Affair!
What am I supposed to do with this?
Oh, put it in the trash.
Okay.
A swimmer in good hands.
Liam.
Hayden!
Thank you so much for the time you get there!
Yeah, she's blacklisted.
You're so tall.
I wish she had rented the movie instead.
I think you have a great day.
All right, let's do some movies now.
Some returns.
Oh!
Who did not rewind the T-Rex?
The hot...
Oh.
One second.
Reserved.
One moment, please.
You can wait one moment, right?
Okay, nice.
Huh?
People say I have no emotions.
Could you recommend a drama to make me feel something?
There you go.
Literally in my hands.
It was fate.
We got lots of horror.
Heart haunting the manch?
Oh, yeah, there it is.
Hello.
She looked happy for someone with no emotions.
Yeah, who told her that?
A mount due.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Have a great day.
You're gonna love the body builder's last melody.
He's great.
Okay, I'm a little traumatized by the last person that asked
for... Oh wait.
Oh no, no.
Take it.
Take it back.
Oh.
You're not gonna throw that at me, are you?
Thank you.
paying two dollars either wait no it's a plastic smile oh
that's so sad she says i smile but i don't feel it it's a
masquerade no thank you very much victoria um um you did
reserve that and i have it right here for you thank you very
much hey have you heard of my story It's really, oh, you
guys, you guys already are coming back.
Have you heard of my store?
Wait, you don't like it?
No thanks.
I prefer a good book over a movie.
Why are you such a hater?
They threw my things away!
They threw my...
They threw my flyers!
They're littering!
Okay.
oh you're already planning okay awesome love you oh oh oh
shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot hello sorry about that i
was out doing 43 dollars
why the women in this game think you have a great day
they're the ones Always getting the naughty movies.
It's kind of awesome.
The women are horny here.
150.
You are free to go.
It do be like that.
You are free to go, Michael.
Need milking farm movie.
I don't think we need that.
I think actually we negative need that.
End of a mystery flick.
The one throwing the flyers on the ground was you.
No, it's not!
I swear, I swear!
Two 13 bodies.
Okay, buddy.
Wow, we made a buku box today.
Look at that.
That's crazy.
We made so much money.
Oops.
I guess everybody's just renting movies.
Nobody knows what to do with their time.
Facebook is not created yet.
Or TikTok.
Or YouTube shorts.
You actually go outside and you find a movie.
You rent it and you watch it.
Yeah, no streaming.
Wow.
Maybe we should buy some more movies.
Let's buy a pack then, right?
The Beast in Miami!
We'll do...
Sailor Gone with the Wind.
That's already a movie.
The Inmate, a Beacon of Hope.
The Tub Gone by Midnight.
The heirloom freak.
show let's let's do random 10 random movies nice what do we
got here you think the two 13 bodies have 28 staff boots all
right what do we got here the relic will see you that
actually sounds kind of spooky the barrel separation guitar
plants the angry trooper dr. Lane's chosen relic dr. Lane's
chosen hack
dr. Lane's chosen hag it's you you are the chosen hag which
one's the sequel I wonder the blood-sucking bathtub the
sounds that sounds too real Satan and his alien
We left the fishbowl behind.
That also sounds like a...
Like a real artsy kind of movie.
A dead teacher in the attic.
Dr. Lane's chosen 35 plus, please.
We probably...
Oh, I have this whole shelf that's been completely empty.
Um...
We should, uh...
We should fill it with sci-fi!
Oh, dang it!
Oh, no, wait.
I should have bought them random movies after we got the
sci-fi!
No!
Well, what we can do...
Well, all these are...
13 bodies.
I do have enough cash, you're right.
What we can do, though, is move the horror to the bigger
shelf.
and then the sci-fi to the...
So we don't even have to buy, like, another shelf or
anything.
All of these are 13 bodies.
So many bodies.
13 of them even.
Or so I've heard.
It's still new, and clearly people are still renting it,
so...
Best freaky movies in town.
These are one-of-a-kind, genuine movies.
Oh.
Reserved.
Nice.
Wait, what was that?
The vengeful ghost is getting reserved!
Yes, yes, yes!
People love it.
People love the vengeful ghost.
All right, let's get our dramas here.
Oh!
Wait.
Oh shoot.
We're out of space.
Alright, it's gonna be a mixed shelf, my bad.
It's gonna be mixed.
Nice.
Where?
We have not seen the T-Rex in a while, have we?
Huh.
Offering of the Tentacle definitely sounds adult.
That's what I thought.
memories going to the rental store friday after school to
see the new vids in vidja for rent that growing up in the
90s was a magical time yeah just wanted to say you were
luckier than you gave yourself credit i got two copies of
nero on my second poll and was able to use my spare gotcha
funds to get three more rare servants yippee oh yeah because
you wanted my luck you wanted my
out um let's see sci-fi market science oh it's free it's
free it's free the milk body snatchers rocket mammoth robo
computer super charged a cloud computer virus
Retirement with my cash.
That's typically how people retire.
Alright, let's go see what we got here.
Ooh, they're green.
I should start color coding them, no?
They created the first paladin.
Pink neon cowboy.
The kennel star cup.
The tentacle living on Mars.
The milk carton blast off!
They came for the Templar!
Steal Duchess on patrol.
Body part alien invasion.
Cup overdrive.
And trophy robots.
I like the green boxes.
Yeah, I should start.
Hold on, let's see.
Alright, this will be for...
Oh wait.
Science fiction.
oh okay oh my bad sorry there we go we can get we can get
two more science fiction oh it's mixed right now there we go
all right let's also make this all green green nice okay
sci-fi is green drama will remain not horror well oh wait
this is like the new ones though yellow no blue and then
this will be horror and it's red sci-fi skills thanks page
why is it the black market six five three two two eight two
sausage and mood based of 42 hello
I'm okay.
Milk carton blast off.
I've got it.
A lot of reserved movies, huh?
Okay.
Um, what was it?
Oh, wait.
Wait, what were the other ones?
Scroll, scroll, scroll, scroll, scroll.
Oh, there we go.
Uh, six time one.
2, 5, 5, 2.
The computer virus.
Computer virus.
A classic.
Save now.
3, 8, 9, 2.
The waitress living on bars!
These are...
Amazing!
Everybody's gonna want the waitress living on...
Look, she even looks like a giant is.
I really like that these images are just like like they have
like a base and then they just kind of insert stuff you know
it's so funny hello guitar brain implants absolutely
reserved wow we have a lot of reservations alright wait wait
I want to see if we can do some decorating.
Decorations?
Oh, we can do a UFO!
We can get a little... Oh, I want the robot!
But he's so expensive!
What's the customizable sign?
What can we make it say?
We'll put this by.
Sci-fi!
Nice!
$99 for the robot.
Default text.
Maybe default text.
Okay, awesome.
The thing showed that... Wait, can I get higher now people?
No, level 6.
What level am I on?
How am I supposed to know?
What does E do?
Oh, nothing.
I am...
Level?
Ugh.
Give me two happy 23 months.
Thank you, Boots!
Thank you.
Bustin, bustin, bustin.
Hello.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
No, you love me.
movies you love them what maybe some other time oh my god
look at this this guy is cure for sci-fi oh hey yeah yeah
yeah come on in come on in come on in come on in come on in
come on in wow what's with all these haters oh come on in
okay i saw the lady here Hmm.
13 bodies?
Yes, I have it.
There you go.
Howdy, Minto.
Howdy.
David.
One dollar.
To you?
Um.
Yes.
The vengeful ghost?
I like how they're so polite.
Um.
Two 13 bodies again.
Okay.
Thank you, come again!
150, huh?
Charlotte, Satan and his hot dog?
That's not an adult movie, by the way.
26 whole bodies.
Oh, yeah.
Body part, invasion.
Oh, Theodore.
Or, enjoy your movies.
You are free to go.
Two ladies, one dessert.
Oh, my gosh.
Calbo, thank you.
so much for the 50 gifted!
The Swimmer in Good Hands and Trophy Robot.
Marianne is gonna have herself a night, baby.
She is down to clown and robot.
Thank you, Stephanie.
This is what nine to five jobs look like.
Isn't it?
Nine to five is supposed to be like an office though.
I guess if you like...
I mean, I don't know.
We're here the entire day.
We're here from 8 a.m.
to like 10 p.m.
I'm okay.
Sorry about that.
There we go.
Okay.
Nice.
Let's do some movies.
Oh, he's back!
The T-Rex.
sexy t-rex he's back he's back oh there it there he is oh no
i lost him again there he is
hello guitar brain implants uh don't i just have that
somewhere guitar guitar brain implants wait did you already
reserve that oh yes
oh all right nice
Immediately!
Scarlet immediately!
With the T-Rex.
It will soon be done.
Thank you!
Hey.
Science fiction.
No way my cough is getting so bad all of a sudden.
Oh.
Sorry.
Ugh.
That smile.
Oh, what a... What the hell is that?
Wait, what is that?
Rainfall?
One, two, three, four, five.
I did it, I did it, I did it.
Thank you very much.
475 for you?
Maybe you need a break.
Oh, well, I anticipated that probably streams for like the
next week will be a little shorter, so...
I'm sorry!
But I got the meds eventually, so...
Hopefully I'll be feeling...
tippity-top shape soon!
Nice.
Why does the music sometimes go away?
It becomes so ominous.
Hello!
Hello, hello, Samantha!
have a good day all right let's go hand out some flyers our
store is empty yeah did you know we're here yeah exciting
huh wow wow i know you've never heard of a movie before ever
oh you're you already know me you know me too anyone else
wait what about that guy wait where'd you come from I missed
a potential customer.
Oh.
As long as Mito's on the screen, the life is good.
Milk carton blast.
Oh.
Let's get these.
I'm out through 13.
Thank you, Layla.
Send it.
I apologize.
Don't apologize for sending one.
I like the skews.
Thank you.
Hold on, let me grab it though.
Let's get it.
6-9-28-29-34.
The saucy snake delivery!
Oh, I didn't even see the price.
I saw the price after I purchased it.
Yes.
One cherry.
Did you guys hear that?
Somebody was knocking on my door.
Ew, is this a horror game after all?
Ew, what was that?
Oh, oh.
13 bodies?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
Probably somebody returned it.
I just gotta...
We gotta find it.
No.
Please!
Nobody returned it.
Oh, the tape dealer knocked!
Oh my gosh, she scared me.
Nobody returned it.
I'm so sorry.
I cannot help you.
Shoot, my movies are all over the place.
Horror!
Horror, horror, horror, horror.
Ghosts, my fantasy.
Drama.
Okay.
Oh, so sorry.
I can't help you.
Sorry.
Don't be sad.
Don't give me that look.
You're making me sad.
I'm out, dude.
Forty-six.
Get out of here, James.
Why did you look so sad at me?
Oh, you're buying out the store.
take your meds I will once I get them okay please please
please I beg you don't charge this two dollar late fee hmm I
will argue with you all day here's your money I'm sorry
business is business buddy business the way they speak in
this game.
It's so funny.
Hi.
Bro renting $50 in boobies and talking about $2.
I know, right.
Oh my gosh, I just realized it's midnight.
This is craziness.
25.
Have a good day.
Night.
Why did you turn so slowly at me like that?
Long shift, yeah.
Holy cow.
I wonder how much we made, though.
It doesn't feel like we made that much money.
I mean, I did spend, like, $100 on...
on, you know.
That adult film.
What do we got here?
The Blood Sucking Paladin.
Keeping my gum machine oiled up.
No.
Sure, we'll get the blood-sucking paladin.
Please.
Please fix my leaky heirloom.
Whatever you're into, I don't judge.
They created the first fairy.
It was a pleasure doing business with you again, sir.
Inspect object.
Wait a second.
Nope, not that one.
The stiff PC.
Um.
Fortunately, it doesn't look like they have descriptions on
the back or anything.
Wow.
We're buying from this very shady individual.
And we're not having any second thoughts about it.
Oh good, we had no sci-fi.
Let's see what.
People returned a few things.
Not the scaly.
Sailing, not the scaly.
I didn't mean to say scaly.
I'm comparing to sailor intent.
I mean scary.
And wait.
What did I say?
Sailor.
The scaly.
I didn't mean to say Scaly.
I didn't mean to.
Alright!
We made $252!
Help 20 customers with their movie requests.
Wait, that means we might be able to get more money.
We might be able to get more money.
Because...
Oh, it's the Harvest Festival!
Oh, look how cute!
Oh, never mind.
This is cute.
Hi!
Oh, you got apples and...
Is that corn?
And carrots and something.
Oh, look at the decorations.
Oh, wow.
Gourds, gourds, gourds, and more.
We got pies.
We got gourds.
We got jams.
This is awesome.
I'm hungry.
All right, we got movies.
Oh, dang it.
I don't mean to grab that one.
Finally, everybody returns 13 bodies.
I'm so sorry to that guy.
He should have just come today.
Let's go, thank you!
My wife!
I'm not feeling better.
But that's okay.
I'm feeling better now that you are here.
I said hi to me.
Calling to reserve 13 bodies, 13 bodies!
Oh, that's not the reserve, the special one is reserved.
Sometimes the movie you want is rented out.
That's the reality of the era.
It truly is.
You gotta be like, on top of it, you know?
If you want, if you want a movie, you gotta be there.
It's like a Black Friday sale.
You got to be lined up, you know?
Remember how people used to line up for Black Friday sales?
Remember when that was a thing?
People would, like, wait outside.
They still do?
No.
No, they don't.
Uh-oh.
Wait, um, we can take you.
Put you there.
Wait, it's still mixed.
Oh, here we go.
Now it's just horror.
Hello!
Skeleton failed studies, I got you!
This one's kind of popular.
Not as much as before, but it still happens.
I did Black Friday once, where I went out pretty...
It was like maybe like a 5am or something.
And...
default text.
It was like...
I don't even think I went.
I think I just was like, oh, I'm going to go to...
I was like Best Buy, I think.
I was like, I'm going to do Best Buy and see if I can get a
good deal on an electronic.
I love me some gadgets.
There wasn't anything specific that I wanted, I think.
Maybe that's where I messed up, but...
Um...
But, uh...
It was not worth it.
I want it and do it again.
Despite there being practically no Black Friday deals
anymore, people will still line up.
I guess it's kind of like, I guess some people think of it
as like a family activity now, you know?
Some people really go with their families and are like,
oh yeah, there's not really any more deals anymore.
It's a vibe, it's a vibe.
We got the two ladies.
Oh, T-Rex is back too?
Wait until they see our new lineup Of please fix my leaky
heirloom And keeping my gum machine oiled up The lotion and
tissues are It's too much, man It's too much I think it's
too much Sorry, we have a random Random horror film Who is
sorting these shelves?
Who?
Huh?
What bozo?
Put this vengeful ghost in the...
Dr. Jarab.
It's a bit on the nose.
Yeah, alright!
Actually, though, that's kind of what I look like right now.
Next to my bed are tissues and motion.
Because I've been washing my hands so much.
Because I'm like, I'm sick.
right?
So I, like, blow my nose and then I want to wash my hands.
But then my hands get dry.
So I have to moisturize them.
Why would you admit that?
Because it's because I'm sick.
I get what the tissues are for, but I don't understand the
lotion.
But don't answer.
I'll just, I'll just, you know.
I'll figure it out, one day.
Do I ever care here?
Hold on.
What decoration?
Oh, I can't get the robot.
I want a frame stand.
It looks fashionable.
I don't know why.
Just like something something like I don't know.
The Minotaur body snatchers!
Ah!
My favorite!
Alright, let's open shop.
Grab, grab, grab, grab, grab.
Don't leave, don't leave.
Everybody come to my store.
Ooh, yeah.
Ooh!
I know, you've never heard of this before.
It's brand new.
Brand new technology.
I don't know.
What do you say?
Me!
Okay, whoa.
It's like packed here.
Okay, wait, hold on.
Wait, I just threw one on the ground.
Where did it go?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Hello?
Pink neon cowboy.
Uh, I think I have that.
No, I don't.
I have no neon cowboys.
Oh, you reserved.
Sure, sure, sure.
Yes, there you go.
Oh.
Hello, Charles.
You are free to go.
Thank you, Jacob.
Taking your good old sweet time, as usual.
Get out of my sight.
So it was Minto who littered.
No!
It wasn't!
That wasn't karma!
Oh my gosh, our store.
Look at that.
There's so many people.
Oh, we're gonna have empty shelves!
Goodbye!
We're gonna have empty shelves!
Oh, the bed.
man of absolute culture.
And he gives me exact change.
This guy rocks.
Hey.
Go ahead.
Charge me your $2 late fee.
I could have returned a thousand movies late.
Do you think I'd care?
I'm rich.
Okay then.
I will.
I will take it.
If you're so rich, Ashley, don't give me an attitude then.
William, with his innocent smile PC.
Okay, buddy.
That's it.
That's all.
He saw what he wanted.
And he said that's what I'm gonna get.
He's a man who knows what he wants.
It looked innocent to me.
Alright, Sophie.
8.5, 7, 8.50.
people do be returning movies oh my god there's so many
potential customers outside hello how can i help you the
swimmer in good hands yes you did yep you yes you did you
reserve that if ashley's actually rich she shouldn't have to
mind paying two dollars Exactly!
Thank you, Marianne.
I'm 50.
Get out of my sight.
And Emma.
I just ran out of water.
Um, um...
One moment, please!
At this rate, I might as well become an adult movie store.
Those are my my most lucrative probably.
You are free to go.
Why does nobody have eye sockets?
Creative choice.
What a nice creeper shirt.
You reserved it.
There you go.
All right, Lawrence.
store will they sell movies about taxes don't say that word
to me don't say that we don't think about these things here
why doesn't anyone have a nose this guy literally has a nose
she literally has a nose bye James whoa whoa whoa the ghost
my fantasy you were trying to hide that underneath there I
saw I saw how many movies you need before their scent
attracts mr.
Kojima you discovered my secret why I opened up this store
to begin with was for mr.
Kojima to Hello?
75 cents.
Hello?
Took them to my store.
Knock out gangster.
That's yours.
All yours, buddy.
Alright.
I'm not judging.
I'm just curious.
Our shelves are almost empty, you guys.
What did you grab?
see oh she gave me a cheeky smile i saw that she was like
nothing she gave me a little over the
shoulder yeah no judgment here and ghostbuster hi hi give me
a horror movie to watch oh boy golly do i have satan and his
hot dog i heard good things about this one i know i'm i
wrote all the
Literally all me.
My girl.
The saucy snake delivery.
Yuki, thank you!
I'm currently in line for Takotori Concert.
Happy birthday!
I can't sing today because my voice is pretty bad.
Uh-oh.
That guy just took the last copy.
Sorry, can I help you?
Yeah, you'll manage.
Happy birthday!
Have fun at the concert!
The guy came for one thing and one thing only.
Satan and his hot dog.
Gosh, business is booming, you guys.
This is craziness.
Maybe we'll be able to buy the robot.
Hey.
It's for horses.
Awesome.
Thank you very much.
Yes, Grandma.
Old movie.
Uh, sure.
Give me one second.
He's in disguise.
Walter!
Your name is Walter.
completely out of movies?
Ma'am?
What's happening?
Ah!
Wait, we still have so many people left to check out.
Enjoy!
Is this old movie?
Old movie?
Ma'am, I have, like, nothing left.
I have nothing.
I can't help you.
Sorry.
Maybe if it It was a return thing.
Walda.
I need to rent this movie, Walda.
Oh my gosh, we're left with two movies.
The werewolf, our last guest, and a scary sailor in the
tent!
Everything else got rented.
That's insane.
Late.
Oh, this is...
It didn't look like a drama to me at first.
We left the fishbowl behind.
Oops.
Alright.
Drama.
So popular.
I know.
This is crazy.
I always thought that...
the way these worked is you pay per day.
What is it?
So you'll get to rent the movie and then you'll...
Oops.
I didn't mean to do that one.
You rent the movie and then you pay late peas if it's late
but you don't rent per day.
Usually it's two or three days.
Ah, okay, okay.
Remember having five to seven days to return?
Oh, huh.
Pay first for X days.
Oh, okay, okay.
That makes more sense.
No return or reserves either.
Wow.
Well, we should have some more returns in the morning.
Um.
Can I buy that, like...
Well, I think it's actually going to be a week soon, no?
For 13 bodies?
Yeah!
Literally tomorrow!
Hi, Mito, hi, Chai!
Hilary's!
Oh, that's right, we got more money here too.
Clam.
Nice.
Some movies were more expensive to rent because they were
new.
Oh, okay.
Wait, but Sunday, we get a new movie.
Nice.
So I do want to get that new movie release.
It wasn't a station, it's the shelf.
I think is good.
We'll get the five.
Actually, I don't even know if I'll buy that many, though.
We'll get it anyway.
And then...
We'll get...
And let's get some more movies.
Alright, alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
So our new release guy...
We'll take over here.
Um...
Right up front...
Ooh, that's fancy-looking.
Fantaholic, welcome to Mambuship, thank you!
New release shelf will cause new releases to sell fast.
Oh, good, good, good.
Um...
Let's make it...
Oh, that doesn't really...
Yeah, like that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright!
Um...
Let's put it, like, in between these two, right?
Well, I assume we'll get fantasy eventually.
I assume?
I'm gonna also make them all the same type.
Uh...
Like there.
Oh wait, this should be...
Yeah, that one should be adult, though.
You know?
This one can be yellow.
I don't know what it's for.
It's for something.
It might be mixed.
Who knows?
And then sci-fi is green.
Oh wait, it's also different.
My bad.
Which one did I...
Oh, that one.
Oh, this one's nice though with the lights.
We'll do this.
Wait, how can you tell the color?
Oh!
We'll do the lights.
I like the lights.
Wait.
Green.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I keep pressing the wrong button, sorry.
Drama.
Yeah, we'll keep that.
Horror.
We'll keep red.
This is aesthetically pleasing now, isn't it?
Nah.
And it matches this light.
Oh, wait.
The adult section, too.
Very nice.
It's a very nice Got an interview on Monday?
Last time you wish me luck on when I got offered the
positions and I'm hoping for the boost again!
Corin!
Good luck!
Alright.
Tomorrow, fall festival.
I wish we could hire somebody.
Oh wait, we got more movies.
Wait, okay, oh, I got another shelf.
I forgot.
Oh, I got a big shelf.
Okay.
that out eventually it'll be blue because blue is cool all
right and decorations movie display jack-o'-lantern coffin
okay so we're like level 4 I guess are you serious they're
all dramas oh oh we got a we got a shiny they're all drama
The Nomad Clown Retirement with my gargoyle My heart never
cold Oh my god The mammal A true burden The race family tree
The fighting duchess The bridge beyond the appliance This
one looks like a brave little toaster no The boat's last day
home The uncle's last day home.
The cauldron.
A true burden.
Oh good, we got some old ones.
Okay, so let's move some of these dramas.
Over here, though.
I wonder if we can get repeats.
How rare that is.
And let's do...
Oh wait, not that.
Let's do this.
make this shelf.
Also, like, horror too.
You know?
I'd rent a movie every day if it was from Min-Tol.
I got the best movies, and I got my dealer in the back who's
supplying them.
You're in good hands.
Is that?
I guess that is flush.
Yeah.
And then we have this one, too.
We'll figure out what to do with it.
Okay, good.
Actually, let's go see if we can buy more movies.
No more bundles.
Maybe I should do the bundle in the...
Black Neon Minotaur.
We could use some more science fiction, I think.
Shiny?
Oh!
Keg in Moonbase 42!
Grandma's troll pie.
Glad I caught you while you're still live.
I got a job!
Redacted years of me who finally added in.
Won't be able to watch live much anymore.
But I'll be in the bots for sure.
Live before ever.
Scuba Gator, congrats!
Congrats!
Aw, we'll be sure to comment so I can at least see how
you're doing and everything.
Congratulations!
Let's see, let's do some more...
I don't want horror, some more sci-fi.
Hmm.
Bad critic.
Sometimes you want bad movies, though.
Sometimes people ask for bad movies.
Good critic.
Or horror drama.
We'll do, we'll grab that one.
Okay, that should be good.
Nice.
No, no.
Waitress stays up.
There we go.
How much we make?
290.
Let's go.
Oh, snack shelf!
Whoa!
Harvest festival!
I'll take one of them, corns.
Snack shelf.
Wait, in here?
Is it the station?
No.
Equipment?
Snack shelf.
No, I can't afford it!
Jesse, thank you so much for the fun!
Get there!
I can't afford the snack shelf.
I should have never bought those other videos.
Oh, this is still considered new.
Awesome.
It's definitely been a week, though.
Okay.
Dang it.
Some customers return their rentals in a broken state.
Unfortunately, damaged movies must be thrown into the trash.
The system automatically adds a broken feed to the customer.
Okay, good.
During their next purchase, the checkout computer will flag
the outstanding feed.
Into the trash.
Oh, put a movie in the trash.
Fun skew?
Oh, thank you.
One second.
Overpriced bags.
on subpar microwave popcorn exactly that's what i'm talking
about well let's take they will come for the heirloom
oops i did it again that's literally the name of the song
oops i did it again played with your heart um
What is it?
Oh, SKU.
The service is expensive, charging more than standard... Ah,
that's why.
It's so expensive!
Sexy dope in the sauna!
I can't even afford it!
Thank you, though.
Satan and his alien.
there sexy what was it sexy gnome in the sauna late so
maybe not horror maybe this could be drama or something or
sci-fi
while we expand I'm losing my voice again.
One moment, one moment, I'm a one person army.
I'm a one person.
Oh, I'm just walking around holding these, holding the stiff
PC.
Hey, hey, tape dealer here.
I put aside a couple of spicy titles for your next visit.
Same days as usual, Tuesdays and Thursdays.
Yes!
Spicy, spicy, spicy, spicy, spicy, spicy, spicy, spicy!
What's today?
Aw, Saturday I have to wait until the meteor shower?
I feel like my shop is looking kind of bare.
Sorry.
Hmm.
We'll move this over here.
it's deceptively christmas but it's not more decorations i
feel like we have so few options look at that hello trophy
robots i got you
oh oops wrong thing there we go christmas in space what else
we got uh equipment is only Oh, we can buy the snack shelf
now.
Okay, awesome.
That'll liven the place up a bit, I think.
We can put it...
Right next to the horror section.
Oh.
Cost 50.
Cruncherzilla.
Moonbike.
Galaxy bar.
Fudge slime.
Hot dog.
Chocolate bar purchases.
I did, okay, I, I've seen some people play this, and some of
the events have like, uh, what's, uh, things, special
things, so this, we gotta get chocolate bars.
You have a copy of Two Girls, One Mint.
I'm sorry, would Two Ladies for One dessert not be enough
for you?
So let's do chocolate bars.
Like a galaxy bar.
Wait.
Fire egg balls.
We'll do a galaxy bar.
Is that costing me money?
Yes, it is.
That should be good.
Open up!
Hello?
Don't leave, don't leave, don't leave, don't leave.
Come to my store, come to my store.
Me!
Come to my store?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Sorry, are you angry at me?
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah!
Oh, you are already coming, you're already on your way.
You, you don't know my story.
You're already on your way.
Why are there so many haters?
You?
You love movies.
No, don't leave!
I'm hypnotizing you.
Oh!
You love them, you love them, you love them.
Yes?
13 bodies?
Right here, ma'am.
Hello!
13 bodies.
You're good to go.
I love movies.
Yes, come on, mister.
Neon pink cowboy.
I know you might be embarrassed about it, but it's a
splendid movie.
Criterion Collection.
Also, Maya, I saw what you were hiding underneath there.
Thirteen body, you were like, I'll get them the newest movie
and then maybe two ladies for one dessert as a little treat.
I see.
Have no shame.
It's okay.
Saw right through her.
Come on.
Thirteen bodies.
$13.
Anybody in the chocolate bars?
There it is!
Our little chocolate bar.
Thanks, Nathan.
Thank you!
Oh, one second.
Something old.
Old, old, old, old.
Oh.
Yep, you're welcome.
Would you like to watch my baby home video?
Ha ha ha ha.
That's old.
Galaxy bar!
Yeah, sci-fi movies really are popping up.
60.
Bees in a man's room.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh yeah, hiding them under... hide again.
Once again, hiding the adult film under the horror.
A classic.
Satan and his alien.
I remember you.
There you go.
They shouldn't... they shouldn't have... they shouldn't
be... they shouldn't be embarrassed.
I remember you!
Oh.
Florence, you got something normal this time.
Oh, okay.
There you are.
Give me the cash.
You're good to go.
Nice sweater.
A lot of people are returning stuff right now.
Thank you.
110.
Is your change?
Have a good day.
Oh my god, this stuff is flying off the shelves, you guys.
Oh.
Hello!
One second!
Please, wait a moment.
Whoa, dapper, doodle!
Trophy robots is for you!
Oh.
Yes?
It's not raspberry, it's blue raspberry, you're good to go.
Willy Wonka over here, yeah.
What was that?
Nothing, I was mistaken.
I thought I saw a black case.
holy cow okay okay susan can we be a little you're gonna
break my stuff can we be a little more careful with the with
the products thank you
my friend's coming over uh a horror movie if it's old that'd
be a nice bonus okay old horror movie the first thing i
picked awesome
take a little extra for yourself out of the register but
this is my business I'm already getting all the money it's
already all mine
trying to restock the candy no way are we already Willy
Wonka gets a candy no there's still so much candy there's
still so much candy okay
Do you need to do customer service with a smile?
No.
Well, maybe.
Patrick, you're free to go.
Oh, and a sci-fi.
All right.
He got a little extra.
Hello?
They don't make movies like they used to.
I miss the movies I grew up with.
You don't need old movies.
Hmm.
This one, Uncle's Last Day Home.
My uncle loved that one.
Hello, grandpa.
Gosh, so many returns.
There's so many returns to do.
Rented.
Or reserved.
Oh.
Is that our guy?
You think?
Hold on, I'll grab that one.
Yeah.
Oh Yes He came immediately.
I just put that up there.
Holy cow.
That guy was like I need I need it.
I need it.
I need it I need it My leaky.
I need please fix my leaky heirloom I need it.
I need it right now
I wonder how upset the people get, like, if they're waiting
for too long, you know?
Uh-oh, I think I just dropped the movie.
My bad.
Yeah, it did.
Um, um.
Yes.
Blood-sucking bathtub.
There you are, alright.
Wow, wee.
Wow.
Betty.
Betty's got the fit.
He was desperate for it.
He came immediately.
He was like, I won't waste a second longer.
I need the movie.
My adult fiction.
Oh, they're doing the...
They're doing the fireworks again.
Oh my goodness, this guy's having a party.
There you are, sir.
Hat dog.
Hat dog, indeed.
Oh my gosh, this is such a specific amount.
16.
75 85 awesome miss frizzle fit yeah she you guys don't
realize but tomorrow she's traumatizing her uh her students
by sending them down someone's esophagus shrinking them down
and just sending them on it i have a late fee excuse me no
one ever told me there was a return deadline i'm not paying
this I'm sorry, this won't happen again.
Yeah.
I'm a no-nonsense lady.
I'm a no-nonsense business owner.
Chocolate far, far better.
That's kind of fun.
Ten cents.
Yeah.
No-nonsense.
Please fix my leg here.
It's you.
Yeah, take care.
her i don't care if i that one oh my gosh what's your name
grace you're gonna love the saucy snake delivery okay take
that oh my gosh it's midnight and my shelves are bare this
lady was like i don't have a choice there's nothing in this
store i can only i can only read adult movies
She's like, also, I'm embarrassed to be seen.
So I have to wear my glasses indoors.
Who are you, Steiner?
Yes, the Galaxy Bar.
Yes!
Buy my snacks!
We're kicking butt at this game, you guys, I think, maybe.
Hmm.
Oh, a grape.
Mmm, yummy.
Okay.
their prescription as he says thank you very much you are
good to go juliet have a great night oh my goodness gracious
what a day what a day i'm exhausted wow
working is hard
Okay, we still have a good...
Wow, we sold almost all of our galaxy bars.
Will Mito hide her saucy movie choice or keep it out?
I'd keep it out.
I think I'd be...
Oh.
Also, Darko, thank you so much for the...
For the dono.
For the tip.
Yeah, I won't tell my bias.
I'll keep the change even.
Aw, too bad someone didn't get to get the hot sexy T-Rex.
Oops.
Who ordered the hot T-Rex?
Sorry, I inserted sexy y'all on my own.
Okay!
Wait, what day is it?
Saturday.
We could get 10 random movies.
What a cute yard.
Okay, sleepies.
Even though I'd have...
Or before his dream.
Also, I haven't had dinner.
So let's buy this.
Bathroom carnage.
Kill the bath.
Kill the bath is awesome.
Intergalactic heirloom endeavor.
Scary Rocket Man flick.
The stepbrother death movie.
Okay.
Sad ape dreams.
Oh, no.
Why is it bad?
Rocket mammoth, android blast off.
The money is here.
Why is it evil?
I keep my movies unwound just for Minto.
Blacklist, blacklist, blacklist.
I've been to Japan multiple times now that browsing the
saucy section no longer embarrasses me.
Have I changed for the better?
Yeah, yeah.
I know, it's kind of funny how like, I don't know, I don't
go to any saucy stores or anything.
Like, at home, but in Japan, I don't know.
I'll just like walk into the Edo game section and be like
okay what do we got the spirit always watching wait this is
like a great price i mean not a great score okay let's see
what our randoms are too the shining what was that hold on
blood creek gas mask oh that's snacks the shining breakfast
at sea the waiter that followed you home scary oh wait this
looks awesome g-force g-force outside racer and then g-force
couch racer bathroom carnage the sorcerer living on mars the
yacht through space the gas mask computer virus the plant
pot blast off
this once and for all is i boo singular or plural or is it a
moose me scenario ibees i be i blee i boo's i boo
i think i boo is a plural too like hello fellow i boo i blee
The beast is here.
The money is here.
I think both are right.
I think so, too.
You guys have been standing here all day.
Please.
Go rest.
Ugh.
Alright, we did the returns.
We got some new movies.
We'll get some more.
More in the morning.
Close up.
355!
Brinto.
We're so close to level 5.
New movie!
The color violet.
Out on VHS today.
Oh no, the cover is so pretty.
The girl's having a great day.
Oh, I'm gonna go see the color violet.
That's what she said.
Maybe.
go buy those.
Ah, order five or more copies.
Can I afford like 10 copies?
I can.
Now this goes next to our new release thing.
Or it doesn't.
Uh.
We need to move some stuff.
Wait, okay, hold on.
If we move it over like that much.
Perfect.
All about the love of life.
A powerful drama worth watching at home.
Don't start winking at the customers when you see which
dirty movie the customer is renting.
Why not?
What if I'm like, T-Rex?
Or, uh...
But if I see, like, leaky heirloom, I'm gonna be like...
If I see a leaky heirloom...
I'd expect a wink.
I'd give you one.
Oh, we even got a special one!
Let's go, let's go!
Ooh!
Nice.
We got a shiny.
All right, what do we got here?
Late.
I like how it kind of organizes these, you know?
So I can grab all the dramas at once?
Wait I just realized, what am I supposed to do with all
these 13 bodies?
Once it's not new anymore.
Wait a second.
Eventually you'll get a clearance bin.
Oh, okay, great.
Sweet buster!
These dudes still say they're new, though, so we can put
them on the new shelf.
Though I feel like we should get a couple more.
Of the...
Of the color violet.
Okay.
Nothing like me, though, to finish off the week.
And also, isn't it like the best feeling going to a movie
store on a Friday?
It's like the best feeling.
Nice.
All right, all right.
It's like that's how you know it's Friday.
Oh, thank you.
It's sticking.
Oh, dang it, I did it again!
Wait, can I throw these?
Throw.
Trying to, like, make it easier, just, you know, to do this
by grabbing the same genre all at once.
There we go.
Okay.
And then we'll fill you up, and we'll put one on here.
Alright, cool.
all the sci-fi's.
Alright.
That and a pizza and you were in business.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Oh, oops.
Those were the days, huh?
Oops.
Those were the days.
Let's do, we can move like these.
There we go.
All right.
Guys, I think I might call it here.
So I could go eat some dinner.
And next time, we will get...
What else can we get?
I don't think I've leveled up in a bit.
Yeah, I haven't.
We'll get...
Television!
And a clearance bin!
Clearance bin is level 10.
Oh my gosh.
candy dispensers arcade maze munch arcade orc invaders and
popcorn machine and everything wow there's so much in this
game and staff yeah next time we'll get we'll get a worker
level six I think that's no I think I'm level four oh yes
yes yes what do you want hello this is Melissa calling on
behalf of sea life awareness we're reaching out about the
urgent situation involving endangered sea turtles may I have
a moment of your time sorry wrong number I don't know if it
was a wrong number or not our little our little UFO make
sure to save your progress thank you give saved yeah don't
you want to buy don't you want to come rent a movie Mida
this dosamito!
Thanks so much!
Also, store expansion.
I know, this game is so much.
We'll probably come back to it, like, periodically, right?
Thanks for the fun streaming, though.
This was a nostalgia trip.
I hadn't really thought about movie rental places in a long
time.
Hope dinner is yummy and you get good sleep and feel better.
And you are free to go is the coolest cashier line ever.
Does that not know what they say usually?
thanks for the stream i remember the time i rented akira a
blockbuster even though i was probably not old enough to
watch it awesome casting good health on the minke thank you
thank you thank you um yeah it's a fun game to play even i'm
glad you guys had fun watching so thanks so much for hanging
out with me thank you thank you thanks so much and I will
see you.
Sorry.
Next time!
On Sanbito!
And on Sanbito!
Bye-bye!